In no matter what anybody wanted to
say about how good the movie was,
what the critics say,
anybody in this business,
if you can do something where it goes
from a thought and it goes to the paper
and you can execute it, how
many motherfuckers can do
that? They don't do that.
People talk shit all the
motherfucking time. But then you say,
how many have you got an can yo, I'm
right movies, give me a strip. Oh hold on,
hold on. I'm almost 30 pages
in. You know what I'm saying?
How many times you that story,
why are they going on? I got it.
I've got a great idea.
All right, what is it?
I remember I was just with Chappelle
show was popping and ludicrous gave me a
lesson out of nowhere. I saw many
airport and I was on Ashy, Larry Hart.
I was I rich bitch man. So I'm like
doing reference like we're even right.
So ludicrous. I was like, Yo Luda
right. He said, what's up Ashley?
I said,
I said Yo,
kill a motherfucker getting a movie or
something cause I just thought that's
what you do.
You just add some motherfucker.
I like it a month I get a movie or
something and he looked at me, Joe,
it was so cold. He looked me
right in my face. He said,
we look for people with ideas and I looked
to him like, well, I have none, right? So
I guess this is this conversation and
it did and when I'm telling you it was a
lesson,
how the fuck you want to ask somebody
for something and you don't got shit to
give them? A lot of guys in the
beginning think that's how you do it.
That's how he did when I was on HBO is
the wires. Motherfucker told me one time,
he said, Yo d can you give
me the number to the wire?
I think I could do this shit.
This motherfucker what the day was like
a hotline from anybody from the streets.
Do you ever thought about being an actor?
You don't want to put those
10 years of getting rejected.
Just call this number and we'll
put you on the wire. You know,
what gets me about acting though is
when someone has never acted before,
it goes in there and kills it.
You know,
like people who are like the athletes in
particular, like rappers have done it.
Like a lot of people have done it,
but some people,
but some people I believe that that,
do you have natural talents? Yeah.